- Just give you quick fun facts.
Sorry to derail the
meeting but I have to,
once pulled a
lottery scratch off ticket
but we were very disciplined.
There was somebody at the
register so I put it back.
Like rung up the person,
person goes,
"I want a scratch off."
I went to the thing
above 'cause I pulled that one.
He goes, "No, no,
I want that one."
I gave it to 'em, person
scratched it off and won $5,000.
And to this day it is still
the weirdest moment of my life.
I lost, when I tell
you I lost my mind,
I ran out of the store.
So the guy scratched
it and loses his mind.
Won $5,000.
I then react by, I mean
my reaction was the greatest.
Way over the top of anything you
ever seen for me screaming like
I saw a ghost.
Ran out of the store went
behind the store and cried.
(group laughter)
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Follow Me" by Anthony Russo)
What I think would
be just fun with this
group and this, you know,
I think we need to start making
some of these meetings look like
this is this is a good time to
just kinda shoot the shit.
I'll throw out a bunch of stuff
but I want to
hear from other people.
I'm very inspired even
the meeting I just had with
Marc Ecko and the
(censored) guys, right?
They're obviously a media
company and had a lot to do with
the stuff that is your
world Ryan but in general...
I guess the punchline being
I want to be aggressively
on the offense with this group.
I think we've been spending the
first quarter of this year on
the defense which I think is
right and I'm happy with the
outcomes and I can taste the
permission of the Vayner name
deployed in
areas to really work.
So, that's
running through my mind.
That's always been on my mind.
Like could be interest, just as
you're living life where you see
your attention go.
(censored) like people
have done that. Right?
And then you got to think about
how you make the
business deal, right?
Like there's two
things that are interesting.
You make one big deal with one
big conglomerate that's big and
stupid or you have to
go and quietly do what
Walt Disney did
with Orlando, right?
You lock up,
you think it's this,
there's 47 big people
that have that and you go and
buy the rights from them,
consolidate it in
five-year deals, in perpetuity.
Level it up to
business as you're thinking.
This was good.
Let Tyler know.
Understanding what's going to
happen over the next 24 to 36
months in reaction to something
that happened is the
key to your strategy.
Just like this.
Cool, we'll see what
that clip looks like.
I'll play with it a little bit.
That's a great example.
First of all, it's
also taking the IP and
putting it into
a different place.
(censored) should've been iPad,
an iPad and iPhone gaming
business 36 months ago
if I walked in 36 months,
not playing Monday
morning quarterback,
I would've moved the IP into the
world where I know the are and
then that would be arbitrage
back into the
physical locations.
There's just a
massive misunderstanding on
what to do with dollars.
("Holla If Ya Hear Me"
by Kweku Collins)
I care about,
you know, lack of politics.
- [Woman] Yep.
- I care about
managing up, down,
left, right.
- [Woman] Yep.
- I care about really
understanding the difference
between traditional
creative and our version of it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- In a world where
it changes constantly.
Make sure you're
good at the craft.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm very simple.
- [Gary] If I care about
Facebook commercials that are
two minutes and a scene
from (censored) or if I like
(censored) or if
I like (censored),
that's what I want to make.
- [Woman] Yep.
- The Alexa voice stuff,
that, influencers, that.
Now we're gonna have
this big creative off-site.
- [Woman] Yeah.
I saw that.
- That will be like
eight hours of like,
this, so I think part
of it, the craft will be
very clear for you.
- [Woman] Yep.
- And the whole kind
of leadership of creative.
- [Woman] Got it.
- So I think besides that
it's a very simple game here.
Be in a place where you don't
feel any insecurity and when you
do, use me and Claude
and everything is easy.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] The album
is out or not out.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Great, so we link it
in the video we're about to do.
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] Perfect.
And is there anything
you want to link to?
The full album or anything tour?
- I think the tour
dates would be perfect.
- [Gary] Okay.
You have a page for that?
- Yeah, it's on my--
- [Gary] Website?
I'll pull it up.
- It's on my website.
I'll find it for you.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] How are the kids?
- Celebrated his
daughter's first year birthday.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Congrats.
- So, yeah, they're good.
- [Gary] I see your
kids on Instagram all day.
- Yeah, that's always.
- [Gary] You're
hardcore Instagram.
- [Man] Yeah. (laughs)
- [Gary] You are.
I see it.
I feel like I see them more now
than when I lived in the same
fucking building as them.
That stuff is so real.
- People like to sing.
People like to interact with it.
- [Gary] 100%.
- You were telling me
about that app that does--
- [Gary] Musical.ly?
- Yeah, Musical.ly.
- [Gary] Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 250 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Super excited,
250, nice round number.
Makes sense to have superstar
John Legend in the house.
DRock, you're excited.
- [DRock] I am.
- Very excited.
- [DRock] Fired up.
- Sueza, thanks for
making this happen. John.
- How are you, sir?
- Such a pleasure, man.
You need to put out music, man.
The big advantage now
of distribution online
is you need at-bats.
Don't fall in
love with that song.
You may love it.
The world may hate it.
You need to put out music.
- [Jamai] Okay.
- You need to put out music.
- Put it out, man
and if people love it,
it'll start to
generate some buzz.
Like people will listen to it.
They'll share it with their
friends and then you'll start to
get more views.
- [Jamai] What if I don't have
the money to put out music as
often as I would like to.
Like quality sounded music.
- Then you're stuck and
you lost like everybody else.
You need to figure it out.
Like Prince was a
janitor in his studio
and the quality now, yeah!
- It's so cheap
to make music now.
Like the money
should not be a problem.
- Jamai, listen man.
- It's really cheap
to make music.
- I love you and I'm trying
to be kind 'cause John's here.
Everything you're
saying is backwards.
You need to do and work.
You're coming up with all the
wrong angles in my opinion and
I'm so pumped you called because
I'm hoping that this is the
breakthrough moment.
Like you need to,
so far I heard,
it's the audience's fault.
It's too far to the left,
the music's too expensive.
You are fully,
fully in excuse mode.
You can put out
plenty of quality music.
To John's point,
it's inexpensive and
if you want it so bad, go
fucking work at the studio
in exchange for studio time.
Like you need to go
out and put out music,
put in the work,
put your head down,
and then figure it
out after the fact.
You need to put out 150 fucking
songs and see how people react
to it before we hear
another phone call from you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, you keep
asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
Got it.
- [Woman 2] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Woman 2] It was
very nice to meet you.
- It was nice to meet
you too, good luck in school.
- Are we shaking?
- No, it's my favorite number.
- Okay.
- It's what I do now.
Five is my favorite number.
Love it, man.
- Thanks, brother.
- [Gary] Take care of yourself.
You know
architect and the mason?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] The fact that it comes
natural to you to buy into the
architecture, that's the
part that holds everybody back.
- [Man 2] Right.
- [Gary] They
don't fully believe me.
- [Man 2] Right.
- [Gary] They don't
believe me they should
eat shit from 23 to 31.
- [Man 2] Right.
- They don't believe me that
at 31 you feel like a kid.
They don't believe like save
your money and don't do shit and
like fucking grind
like work 18 hours a day,
like they don't believe that.
Be the bigger person,
somebody upsets you,
like eat it.
- Right.
- They don't believe that.
So, if you believe that, when
you're fucking halfway home.
And now, the only other part is
do you actually know what the
fuck you're talking about?
- Right.
- Like how many brands
do you follow on Facebook?
Do you read AdAge?
Do you read TechCrunch?
Do you talk, do you listen?
- [Man 2] Student of the game.
- [Gary] Student of the game.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] Do you
know the X's and O's?
- [Man 2] Right.
- [Gary] Like do you know how
to coach the kids but do you
actually know the X's and O's?
- Fast forward, my first real
job was working as a doorman
and there I learned
opening up doors
for people
opened up doors for me.
- That's cool.
- So I took that same
lesson my parents taught me--
- How old were you?
- I was 18.
- So I think the one thing that
other peeps that have grey hairs
and start losing their hair will
tell you is make sure you're
mentally prepared for
the foundation of the
ground to be shaky.
Because I think you've got, at
least from what I heard and the
reason I'm giving you that
advice is I think you've got
stuff figured out.
- [Man 3] Mhmmm.
- Other than when the football
field turns into a hockey arena.
- [Man 3] 'Cause I
haven't been through that.
- That's right. And that
experience is real tricky.
- [Man 3] Mhmmm.
- Especially if
you're overextended and
not sitting on enough liquid.
- [Man 3] Right.
- Like I haven't even
invested in anything in a year.
Real pleasure, man.
- Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Keep up the good work.
("Dusk Air" by The Muse Maker)
You coming with or no?
Hey.
- [Man 4] Gary.
Dude, you mind if I
get a picture with you?
- Sure, no worries.
- How are you?
Man, I've been
following you for a while.
It's really nice to meet you.
- Yeah, have a good day, man.
- [Man 4] Thanks man, you too.
- [Gary] It's the
shadowboxing thing.
Please make a commitment to
every trend that you think is
coming because that is
how you win consistently.
Even my dick shit,
I write four articles a year.
I win for everything, as soon
as I know Musical.ly is gonna
matter, I write four
Musical.ly marketing things and
I win every time.
So the one thing you
have to think about is can you
predict/really move very quickly
on very small micro
trends in your demo.
Like sweet pea masks, like if
you think sweet peas are gonna
be smashed up and be
face masks, like nine,
a year from now, you have to
jump as quickly as possible on
those because that
is absolutely winning.
That is absolutely winning.
Like in the world where, one
thing I know from all the media
companies like founders and
people I talk to is where they
all have the best ninjas
they can have and all fighting.
The one thing is who's the first
person who was right that
Clif Bars were gonna be big or
fucking raccoon eyes or
fucking like shadowboxing.
So that's an editorial, you need
to basically write shit before
it actually happened or
literally create
the fucking trend.
- [Sid] A good piece of
content that goes up there
goes to like 160, maybe 170.
The best I think
I've seen is around 230
but that was very rare.
'Cause we need more
written piece of content and
I know you know that.
- [Gary] We need
to get a writer.
Talk to Andy about that.
("Comfortable" by Krid)
(audience cheering)
Dude.
- [Darren] 'Sup, brother?
- [Gary] Hey. Congrats.
- [Darren] Thank you, thank you.
- Standing back there and
listening to the utter love that
is coming out of this room and
the mic and the ridiculousness
that's going on over there.
(audience laughter and cheers)
I'm really excited I stopped
by so congrats my man.
I appreciate that you love
the hustle as much as I do.
I'm humbled that
you share my shit.
I love that you guys
love this man so much.
And I'm super pumped
I stopped by for a kiss.
- [Darren] Thank you, thank you.
I got to talk to
you for a second.
Thank you.
- Okay. You're welcome.
Oh, we're doing a cheers?
I was born in Belarus
in the former Soviet Union
so this how we do it.
This means "to good health."
Zazdarovje.
(audience cheers and applause)
("Comfortable" by Krid)
We live in a weird life.
Yeah, yeah, I mean like once in
a while shit just hits me and
I want to do stuff for fans.
That was, I'm really
glad we did that.
Yo, you should
really put out, yeah,
the video where
he's explaining it
that we can chop
down is incredible.
I want to go into a
different place which
is we have to know our craft.
Like it's important for
everybody here to be deeply
curious, deeply skilled,
and deeply passionate
about Facebook commercials.
About influencer marketing.
About Alexa voice.
You need to follow what I'm
putting out to the world and as
a company we need to do better
job as an org and I need to do a
better job but one of
the things is there's no,
I'm not hiding from this.
I'm putting it out.
Like it's there everyday.
It's in the water and so I think
whether that's you're the kind
of learner that okay, you'll
just go and read about Alexa
voice stuff or watch videos or
if you need anything from me or
the center, I think it's super
important that you're focused on
the things that the
organizations focused about.
And I don't think it
takes that much effort to know.
One of the things I hear a lot
from people is we need this,
we need this and I'm like it's
one thing if a kid says that.
But, like, anybody at this table
like if you're not capable of
reaching out or doing a little
homework or paying attention to
the tea leaves you
can't play at this level.
I think it's super important
that if the world is at A and
what I just
described as Z and I,
Gary, am at like R and T,
I need you guys to
move away from B and C.
Because that's where we are
as a collective as leaders.
Cool, thank you.
("Follow Me" by
Anthony Russo)
10:39, (chuckles)
going to my next meeting.
Obviously, I'm sure you just saw
great meeting with a bunch of
leaders at VaynerMedia.
Felt good, cool tone, right?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
Was really mellow.
- Mellow and like tight.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
It was like chill but
it was very productive.
There was a lot of--
- Calm confidence.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Other Tyler] That's a
good way to put it.
- Yeah, calm confidence.
Got to get that calm confidence.
Kids, alright, one more meeting.
Get home probably
close to midnight tonight.
Early day tomorrow,
so nice solid grinding
executing, operating day.
It's been really unusual I've
been home like for like a month.
Unheard of for me.
Lot of serendipity.
Bunch of cancelled west coast
trips and stuff of that nature
so it's been
interesting and productive.
Going in for my meeting.
Good day.
There's the trash.
Like a lot of
people's strategies.
Good night.
(laughs) That was perfect.